[Aplausos]
[Música]
muy buenas tardes a todos
tú vienes del mar
yo vengo del mar la vida nació en el mar
y tuve la fortuna a los 4 años de edad
de la mano de mis padres ponerme una
careta por primera vez y poder descubrir
con mis propios ojos lo que había debajo
de esa gran masa de agua que es la que
le da el color a nuestro planeta y cómo
no maravillarse y en mi caso enamorarme
de ese mundo submarino el cual empecé a
conocer ya descubrir con sus colores
inimaginables
con sus formas
impresionantes luego con el tiempo a los
siete años pude por venirme un tanque un
cebo
y en mis travesías en el mar descubrí
que habían peces que vuelan y aves que
bucean
también pude observar a esos tiburones
que mucha gente les tiene pánico con su
boca abierta dejando que unos pececitos
pequeñitos les limpiaran sus dientes
también tuve la fortuna de estar debajo
del agua con delfines con esas miradas
inquisidoras son rarísimos son
bellísimos pero también con estos
gigantes del océano las ballenas
jorobadas las ballenas jorobadas que
llegan cada año a nuestras costas
colombianas y que provienen desde la
antártica realizando la migración más
grande del reino animal estos grandes
mamíferos marinos se alimentan de las
especies más pequeñas que son el
plancton este plancton que también es
hermoso cuando se ve en los microscopios
y que gran parte de estos animales son
los que producen
la mitad del oxígeno que nosotros
respiramos
a los 19 años me convertí en instructora
de buceo porque yo lo que quería era
estar debajo del agua
y empecé a trabajar como instructor de
buceo empecé a llevar a mis turistas a
mis clientes a bucear por colombia por
varios sitios del mundo pero una vez oí
que estaba en la isla de gorgona esa
isla colombiana también en el pacifico
el colombiano escuché escuché que decían
por allá lejos hay una isla que está
llena de tiburones y yo lleno yo quiero
ir allá y me puede montar en el segundo
viaje de instructores y llegué a este
sitio una isla oceánica que se encuentra
a 500 kilómetros del oeste buenaventura
son aproximadamente 36 horas de
navegación para poder llegar a esa isla
cuyas paredes descienden hasta los 4000
metros de profundidad
pero ahí empezamos con mis compañeros
instructores de buceo a conocer cada uno
de los diferentes sitios que podíamos
empezar a bucear y ahí te conocí y ahí
me volví a enamorar
me enamoré de ver que las especies en
este sitio no tenían miedo se acercaban
no huían poder ver la biodiversidad
poder ver esos grandes cardúmenes de
peces con sus múltiples colores como ya
lo dije pero esto fue lo que realmente
me impactó estas grandes escuelas de
tiburón martillo
unos tiburones que muchos dirán uy qué
peligro qué cosa tan horrible a mí en
este momento era cuando pensaba dios
existe
en
las diferentes ideas las cuales tuve la
oportunidad de ir a malpelo
pude
tener vivencias maravillosas pero
también tuve unos momentos horrorosos y
tuve que ver barcos anclados sobre el
coral destruyendo el fondo pero también
me encontré con barcos donde sus puentes
estaban cubiertos
de tiburones mutilados
tortugas marinas
que teníamos permanentemente que estar
sacando el agua porque estaban enredadas
ya sea en plástico o en redes de pesca
todas estas imágenes eran realmente
impactantes
barcos atuneros pegados a la isla
pescando en frente de los turistas que
quedaban realmente impresionados suecia
uy vamos a usar ya pronto vamos a quedar
metidos debajo de una red
tiburones como ya lo dije mutilados y en
las calles de buenaventura esas fotos de
las aletas de tiburón secando
es en ese momento que digo esto no puede
ser así es tiempo de actuar y es ahí
cuando tomé la decisión que iba a luchar
por ese lugar
tuve la oportunidad en el año 92 de
estar buceando en el caribe y de
encontrarme con el presidente gaviria y
el presidente si a usted le gusta bucear
tiene que ir a malpelo el vino le
entregué todas las firmas que había
recolectado a lo largo del tiempo para
que él me ayudara a que el área se
volviera un área protegida fue así que
bajo el gobierno del presidente samper
el área marina protegida se convirtió en
un santuario de fauna y flora pero
desafortunadamente cuando entré a
trabajar ahí en el año 98 no teníamos
presupuesto fue por eso que decidí
fundar la fundación malpelo y otros
ecosistemas marinos la cual dirijo en la
actualidad y desde el 2009 el gran apoyo
del fondo patrimonial de malpelo el cual
un gran aliado ha sido conservación
internacional y el fondo para la acción
ambiental y la niñez
después de un tiempo de estar buceando
más de 10 15 años en las aguas de
malpelo tuve el mejor regalo de mi vida
y fue
un día estaba buceando con mi amiga
sandra nado a 40 metros de profundidad y
siento una presencia nada más y nada
menos que este gran tiburón tiburón que
nunca lo habíamos visto era un tiburón
de 5 metros
paso encima de mi amiga sandra que es la
que está tomando fotos ahí
y las dos decidimos perseguirlo irnos
hacia la profundidad
y cuando llegamos a un poquito más
profundo nos dimos cuenta que había otro
y es ahí donde digo quiero saber de qué
se trata y empiezan unos estudios quería
saber qué tiburón era
por ahí en esos mismos años en el año
2000 después de haber visto ese tiburón
tan hermoso tuve la oportunidad de irme
a sudáfrica por una revista national
geographic cuya portada era las fauces
del tiburón blanco pero dentro de dentro
de la había un artículo donde estaba un
señor que se llamaba andrés arman eso se
llama y le estaba tocando la nariz al
tiburón y yo lleno yo a ese señor lo
tengo que ir a conocer y me fui para
sudáfrica pude ver al tiburón blanco en
su medio natural pero también pude
conocer una tecnología con la cual
estaban siguiendo a estos tiburones en
ese viaje también tuve la oportunidad de
conocer al papá de mi hijo hoy mi hijo
tiene 17 años y siempre
de pequeño me acompañó en mis jornadas
cada vez que iba a la isla hasta cierto
momento
en el 2004 los cuatro países costa rica
panamá colombia y ecuador firmaron el
acuerdo san josé donde se comprometían a
proteger integralmente sus áreas marinas
protegidas y a velar por la conservación
de la región en ese entonces me convertí
en la
encargada de la red científica de este
corredor marino de conservación
realizamos una primera expedición
científica donde invité a investigadores
de las islas galápagos de la isla de
coco y vinieron fred wheel
otras personas muy importantes en el
medio de los tiburones y el marcaje y
este administra profesional que además
antes era cazador submarino vino a
ayudarnos a instalar unos aparatos en la
en los tiburones es una un arpón al cual
se le cambia la punta y se le pone el
talle es la forma como nosotros podemos
seguirlos básicamente para que ustedes
den una idea como funciona se le pone el
tag al tiburón
y este en la medida que va
nadando cuando pasa cerca de unos
receptores que hemos instalado
debajo del agua cuando él pasa cerca el
día el número del tiburón
y la fecha quedan registradas en ese
aparato ese mismo aparato nosotros lo
pudimos instalar no solamente en malpelo
sino también lo hicimos en las otras
islas
de la región del pacífico oriental
tropical entonces nosotros empezamos
hicimos hemos hecho más de 40
expediciones científicas y
multidisciplinarias donde hemos invitado
investigadores de varias
de varias ramas unos estaban en aves
otros estaban en corales otros en peces
endémicos etcétera etcétera y nosotros
desde la fundación nos enfocamos a
marcar con telemetría satelital y
acústica diferentes especies de tiburón
entre ellas el tiburón martillo los
grandes tiburones ballena que es el pez
más grande el océano las mantas [ __ ]
los tiburones sedosos los tiburones
galápagos y finalmente el monstruo como
lo llamamos localmente malpelo que era
ese gran tiburón que tuve la fortuna de
ver por primera vez con vida que se
conocía muerto más lobo con vida
y estos son los movimientos de varios de
los tiburones que pudimos ver como ven
se mueven en toda la región
con todos nuestros compañeros
investigadores de la región que ya va
desde méxico hasta chile estamos
compartiendo nuestra información y hemos
podido determinar que estos animales
migran y hay una gran conectividad no
solamente entre las islas sino también
con el continente
también nuestros estudios han demostrado
que las poblaciones de tiburón martillo
han disminuido drásticamente
gracias a todos nuestros estudios
nosotros hemos logrado apoyar al
gobierno tanto a parques nacionales como
a la armada y a diferentes instituciones
para que el área protegida sea más
grande y recientemente en el año 2017
logramos ampliar la nuevamente a 27 mil
kilómetros cuadrados tenemos un trabajo
con panamá y tenemos un trabajo que
hacer obviamente con la pesca ilegal
los últimos tiburones que nosotros
marcamos en el marzo de este año fueron
hembras preñadas embarazadas y éstas
podemos ver que emigraron hacia la costa
nos fuimos hacia allá y en la costa
básicamente donde es el golfo de tribugá
el pacífico chocoano
esta zona bellísima de mangles
y aquí encontramos nuestra área de
crianza de los tiburones martillo
ustedes imaginan encontrar el lugar
donde los bebés tiburones martillos los
grandes que vemos en malpelo nos
encontramos en ese sitio y hemos
empezado a trabajar con las comunidades
precisamente para tratar de salvar este
relicto tan importante
sin embargo
cuando llegamos ahí al puerto a esta
zona de tribugá nos vimos con varios
problemas nuevamente se quiere se está
hablando de construir un puerto el
puerto de tribugá lo cual tal vez sería
apoyar a la extinción de esta especie
críticamente amenazada encontramos
plástico y micro plástico un problema
dramático pero otro de nuestros estudios
muestra los grandes niveles de mercurio
que tienen todas estas especies de
tiburones debido seguramente a la
minería ilegal de oro que viene desde
las montañas y que llega al mar estamos
destruyendo nuestro planeta
por el planeta y colombia especialmente
es un país maravilloso con múltiples
ecosistemas un país variado con una
biodiversidad increíble somos el país
con mayor biodiversidad por kilómetro
cuadrado
tenemos un país como ningún otro que
donde perdamos esta biodiversidad que es
nuestro capital natural estamos fritos
estamos mal
por eso mi invitación es que sigamos
conociendo sigamos investigando sigamos
explorando no tengamos miedo
estas especies que están ahí merecen
lo mismo que nosotros seres humanos
porque también somos seres vivientes y
somos animales y no por miedo podemos
exterminar así que mi mensaje es tenemos
un solo planeta donde podemos vivir y
esta es nuestra vía láctea solo un
planeta
así que
como podemos cada uno de nosotros apoyar
para ser mejor desde bogotá
desde las montañas y ver como nuestro
comportamiento
se va a ver reflejado en el medio
ambiente así que yo les dejo simplemente
está este mensaje donde la vocación es
el que va a dar tu poder necesitamos
ayuda de todos para salvar nuestro
planeta muchas gracias
[Aplausos]